joining us now with more author of the
book bestseller guilt by accusation
Harvard Law Professor Alan Dershowitz
Texas congressman also former prosecutor
Louie Gohmert is with us good to see you
both
the professor I'll start with you
tonight okay
when the Supreme Court when there's a
conflict between the judicial and
executive branch I will defer to you
professor and the executive branch seeks
a remedy like in the case of executive
privilege and the court decides to take
it up
I would think seeking remedy in the
court is the constitutional thing to do
they didn't want to wait for the court's
decision which I would anticipate some
time in oh maybe June what do you think
professor absolutely right checks and
balances and separation of powers
requires that when the president or
anybody in the executive branch is asked
to disclose material that might be
covered by executive privilege the
executive branch has an obligation to
say no to the partisan House of
Representatives committee and say look
if you want to have a subpoena
recognized go to court get the court to
validate it that's what they did in the
Nixon case that's what they did in other
cases but to hold a president
impeachable on obstruction of Congress
for simply exercising his constitutional
authority as head of the executive
branch to impose and invoke checks and
balances and judicial review would make
Alexander Hamilton turn over in his
grave in Federalist 78 he says when you
have a conflict between the two branches
the umpire is the judicial branch so the
Democrats in the house should have gone
to court they could have done it on an
expedited basis and sought review and
sort enforcement they probably would
have won some of them probably would
have lost the Bolton case because that
is as the president said in the
interview paradigmatic example of
executive privilege getting advice from
your national security adviser about
national security issues the courts
would generally uphold that claim of
executive privilege maybe others they
wouldn't but you cannot expect the
president has head of the executive
branch simply to capitulate to a
partisan majority in on a committee
Congress let me ask you louie gohmert
because I read the Constitution and I'll
defer to you and professor Dershowitz
both lawyers but my reading is that it
is the sole power of the House of
Representatives to impeach that is their
role but as that is their only role the
trial it is the constitutional role of
the US Senate and it is the Chief
Justice that will preside over the the
hearings now they've impeached this
president they're going to have managers
now present their case to the Senate
okay now I know some Republican senators
or maybe saying well maybe we should
call other witnesses but if it's the
houses role to impeach my question is
why would the Senate not do anything
except listen to their case and not do
the take over the role the
constitutional job of the house can you
help me with that well of course you're
right about that and professor
Dershowitz has made it very clear too
that the only real abuse of power is by
the House of Representatives in
demanding that the president not to
protect executive privilege I mean not
go to court to get it defined so yeah
the house did not do its job on
impeachment there was no high crime
there was no misdemeanor there was no
treason robbery they dropped all of
those things so the we know and you and
I have talked about it Sean when the
Democrats are accusing the president of
Republicans of doing something that's
exactly what they were doing it's
projecting the abuse of power the
obstruction of Congress that's exactly
what they've been doing and all of the
garbage about clear and present danger
we've got act now we've got to violate
our own rules and not allow the minority
party to have witnesses we have got to
move forward and then sit on it for a
month or so that just shows the
apocrypha and we haven't the majority
has not done its job in the house and
you're right to the the trial ought to
go ahead work real quick I'll give
a professor just quick 15 seconds do you
agree with Lois on that and me on that
yes I do and Hamilton again in
Federalist 65 said you need a speedy
trial you need to have a trial right
away impeachment and removal are part of
the same process and it undercuts the
process when there's undue delay for
partisan tactical reasons all right guys
thank you both for your insight very
insightful is be very helpful next week